le 18 juin 1940 pierre gauthier est un
jeune lycéen plongé dans ses révisions
du baccalauréat à peine obtenu il
intègre la résistance en afrique du nord
pour mener combat jusqu'à la libération
du pays
69 ans plus tard face à ces élèves de
cm2 il est venu partager son histoire
date non anecdote il n'a rien oublié
a été variable il ya des familles et des
gens qui étaient heureux de nous voir
arriver d'autres moins heureux c'est
mieux c'est quelqu'un qui témoigne que
ça s'est vraiment passé comme ça y'a
plus de détails c'est enfin des fois il
ya des choses qui sont plus importantes
des choses qu'on connaît pas des choses
qui sont plus difficiles comme ce
monsieur pierre gauthier qui qui par
exemple a perdu des camarades mais c'est
assez émouvant
de parler cash certains de ces écoliers
ont pu évoquer la seconde guerre
mondiale avec des parents elle est au
programme de ces futurs sixièmes
l'événement finalement pas si loin en
intrigue les jeunes générations je vois
que
la plupart des enfants sont intéressés
par ce la seconde guerre mondiale
les problèmes que ça a posé aux
populations
qui ont beaucoup souffert
des événements de guerre tout au long de
l'année l'office des anciens combattants
organise ce type de rencontre des
instants des changes pour perpétuer la
mémoire